[Music]
muscles people are interested in
obviously mainly as a food but if you
buy fresh muscles you'll see this little
bit of hair that is sticking off of your
your muscle and actually this is the
Abus people know it as the beard TheBus
is uh kind of the the literal Lifeline
of the muscle and the muscle has evolved
these fibers as a way of really sticking
very strongly in this environment where
crashing waves are constantly coming
trying to rip them off these surfaces
even though it has this incredibly
strong attachment the really wild thing
we realized is that some muscles would
actually jettison their entire business
and the muscle can do this essentially
instantaneously so these two things for
us just didn't match what makes this so
strong yet easily
[Music]
releasable my name is Matthew Harrington
I'm a associate professor at Gil
University in the chemistry Department
our group is called bioinspired
processing we try to understand how
living organisms make materials and how
we can learn from them to make our own
materials better I've been studying
muscles since 2003 so because we have
these 20 years of experience studying
this system we can start to ask really
really deep questions about how this all
works and how this is made the business
is not a living tissue it is made up
entirely of proteins the fibers of the
abysus are incredibly tough they're as
tough as Kevlar and they're extensible
they're stretchy they can stretch to
double their length so all the
individual fibers are attached to the
stem like branches on a tree and then
the stem is anchored into the living
tissue like roots of a tree the
connection between the living muscle
tissue in the non-living bses can be
very strong when it needs to but it can
also be released with apparently no
Force what the muscle does is actually
let go of the roots so they get pulled
right out of the living
tissue understanding how Nature has
successfully designed such an interface
has a lot of benefit for for inspiring
engineers and material scientists and so
we decided to get a closer look at these
tissues we really quickly saw that the
stem divides into about 40 to 50
different sheets we call these the lam
we could see the living tissue the
non-living Lamela and then something in
between them that we didn't know what it
was once I saw that I was really
intrigued and I and I felt like we could
do something really interesting with
technique called focused ion beam
scanning electron microscopy you can
reconstruct these images into 3D models
that allow us to see these tiny little
features in the living t tissue you have
extracellular Matrix and what's between
the lamel and the extracellular Matrix
are
cilia so cyia are like tiny hairs that
are on the surface of living cells there
are literally billions of these tiny
little hairs just in perfect contact
with this non-living tissue so it was
really clear to us at that point that
there was something going on with the
cyia we we think that the cyia are only
having very weak physical interaction
with the lamelo but it's the fact that
there's so many of them there's billions
and billions of these interactions that
then create friction that allows it to
be so strong it's analogous a little bit
to gecko adhesion so gecko feet are
covered with these tiny hairs called
cite and they can use this to scale
walls and and crawl across ceilings and
by combining the strength of all these
hairs they get friction so actually it's
it's not that surprising that the
interface between the Celia and the lame
is strong what is surprising is that it
can also be released with apparently no
Force when we started noticing the role
of Celia in this whole process we found
this paper that showed that Celia on the
gills of the muscle use
neurotransmitters to increase the speed
of beating of the Celia so we injected
the serotonin and then the thing just
popped right out and I was astonished
honestly we were able to see that if we
added more serotonin the forces that
were required to pull out the stem and
got weaker and weaker we actually
dissected out the tissue the cyia were
beating and then when we added serotonin
they started beating faster when we
added margalene which was a serotonin
inhibitor they slowed down so it really
convinced us that these cyia are
actually the critical players in this
whole process maybe the sensing of this
Cube whether it's chemical mechanical
temperature whatever can then trigger
the release of a
neurotransmitter that can then very
quickly execute this plan of let's let
the business go and it allow the muscle
get out of danger quickly as quickly as
a muscle can get out of
danger you know it's really seldom in a
scientific career where the Pieces come
together so
nicely but I do see that down the line
there might be some potential impact on
the way that humans design uh implants
whether Advanced bio medal devices it's
just an incredible system that that has
been evolved through nature and you know
every time I think we've got them
figured out every time I think now we
know everything there's a new curveball
gets thrown at
[Music]
us